you're like level one germ dude yeah
yeah I'm not I'm not too pressed unless
it's you know I was it's when I see
nasty fools then I get like hold your
breath around this yeah but it say it
takes a lot to get to that point where
you like The Germ when when you get to
the point where everybody
then it's like you you a little
excessive
[Music]
perfect what's up guys I'm Thomas
dopasiola whatever you want to call me
welcome back to the dope as usual
podcast I'm here with my co-host Marty
O'Neill what's up guys guys you know the
stove's usual podcast we're gonna talk
about life drugs problems
accomplishments and everything in
between today we have a very special
guest this is Lil Russell how you doing
dude ah I'm doing lovely thanks for
being here honored it's early that we
seem alert I know because everybody's
usually like yeah you guys are high
already nah we're chilling it's the
early morning look at this for being
here appreciate you YouTube so I want to
start off
real quick I just want to get straight
into this you're from the bay I'm from
Merced I used to go to the Bay often
that's why I go there often so
you're five years younger than me but if
you're from the bay you have to be
influenced by the music around you of
course so I got some CDs in my
collection I busted out I want to see
what these mean to you or if they do
come on all right let's start off start
off strong come on is Mac Dre the street
album
um this is the jacket yeah the street
that was my favorite incredible yeah I
just wanted to see because I want to see
people's faces when I say A Certain like
yes that's hilarious the jacket is an
absolute Legend you know uh I was like
um younger when he was really running
yeah you didn't get to get into Jacka
tough until later you know I like I only
knew jacket for the hit for the
beautiful lifestyle and the stuff that
you would hear on the radio yeah like
later in life but yeah legendary man
shout out to Jack I just want to make
sure okay of course I got a few come on
all right here we go
conversation with the devil and Andre
Nickatina I never got it there you go I
can't wait for you to listen it's one of
my favorite albums I get to keep these
oh I'm sorry these are my all right
these are my babies Oh I should have
said to begin with like by the way
Andre Nickatina because I only remember
his verse on beautiful lifestyle and I
was like I'm not that impressed but but
I've been seeing his name for a long
time and my boys be like you got to be
100 nicotine so I gotta go see what's up
I have to bro you have to what's your
favorite Andre Nickatina song
that's real hard is it he got him like
that oh yeah it goes back to dredon in
the 90s he's probably got like 15 albums
oh they're great oh you oh yeah oh I
can't um all right here we go you're a
little younger so here we go I don't
know if you remember this J Stalin so me
and my pops me and my father used to go
to Rasputin like every Tuesday right and
J Stalin was one of the artists from the
Bay who had his stuff in Rasputin so I
got the I really got to sit with it in
high school that's why I'm saying like
when he started popping you were what
just hitting High School yeah like
freshman year and we was walking around
the school with it on the phones like
you could have not hear J styling I just
recently met J Stalin for the first time
so beautiful man just to embrace like
he's so deserving that my man got
Studios clothing lines like he really uh
like the blueprint for Independence like
he did it he did it this is the man
right that's the one yeah I met him when
I was 17 they let me in the 21 and up
section at the Catalyst and I remember I
met him in Santa Cruz
I don't know if you remember this though
but I really really wish he would have
done more but do you remember roach
Giggs of course I remember
yeah wow that's the first print a legend
yeah I got that from Sam what happened
to Rose again I don't know
what happened he was popping so hard he
was going crazy going so hard that he
was about to get freshman XXL right or
freshman or whatever it was and then it
just never happened I wonder he must he
must have just didn't enjoy that maybe
he had like a bunch of kids or
somebody's like you know what I'm gonna
go get a do something else something had
to have happened because he was popping
too hard
all right here yeah he had a moment what
were you doing so Merced was like did
y'all just listen to Bae music like
y'all just that was my my sister and my
cousin uh used to run street light
records right next door to Santa Cruz uh
Catalyst right so I was just really into
music and I would just go in there I
used to get all the meet and greets
early because I was a young kid and the
street wears place called so fresh like
all this shireen's little brother let
him through the line so I got to hang
out with the rappers when I was a little
ass kid but I was always into the music
that's why I got all these signs and
like these rare ass CDs because I was
like wait a minute what else you got
what were you doing when you first heard
this
oh I'm the king I'm not yourself on the
genie yellow lamb stop playing this is
like ah Dre wrapped the jewelry with the
clear Stones Get on the [__] head like
some headphones something is fitted with
a Clear Tone get your attention the
biggest thing since the TV invention man
I was on the bus first time I heard that
same yeah man I don't I don't even
remember but we had a lot of bus rides
with that man Dre is uh in Vallejo Dre
is as big as Jay-Z 100
like like he is our whole he's our
flight bruh everything the and it's
crazy for one person to have so much
cultural impact to where the entire
region talks like him and dances like
him and like the fashion everything is
derived from Drake and 40 but Dre um the
characters the personality
shout out and not shout out but hey
ecstasy need to be paying Dre's family
like they really need to be running
every percent for all the drugs that was
so you feel me I'm not hurting nobody
but my body body
say that all the time I love that line
man so yeah that's legendary yeah this
really fueled my drug nights I I I
understand that
[Music]
perfect remember those New Year's goals
you promised yourself you stick to hello
fresh is here to help you eat better by
delivering directly to your door fresh
ingredients and easy recipes taking the
hassle out of dinner time spend more
time doing the things you love instead
of going to the grocery store like Marty
said let Hill fresh take the hassle at
dinner time they're going to deliver
fresh recipes fresh ingredients to your
door ready to go guys how much is your
time worth are you a nutritionist you
got time to be driving to the store
through traffic wandering around the
aisles putting together recipes doing
all this research no you don't your
time's worth more than that hellofresh
is saving you time saving you money
making you healthier you know what it's
like to look in your fridge and go
there's like nine things in there I can
make but I don't know recipes I can
Google it hellofresh helps you eliminate
all that every week they're giving you
40 new recipes so you're F you can't
even eat 40 times in a week but if you
can hello fresh is there to help you out
go to hellofresh.com
yola65 and save 65 off hello fresh with
free shipping that's hello fresh.com
forward slash yola65 and don't forget to
use code Yola 65 that's going to get you
65 off your whole order plus free
shipping remember it doesn't get any
better than that for America's number
one meal kit
foreign
[Music]
if saving more and spending less is one
of your top goals of 2023 then why are
you still letting yourself get taxed on
your mobile phone plan switching to Mint
mobile is the easiest way to save this
year as the first company to sell a
premium wireless service online only MIP
mobile lets you save a ton with plans
starting at just 15 a month and order
from home it honestly makes no sense to
pay more for a phone plan when you can
get the same exact thing like Marty said
for 15 a month it's easy it's online you
don't have to go there sit for 40
minutes with somebody while they set up
your phone this is online service to you
at starting at just 15 a month so if
you're looking to save money this year
look into mint mobile they're offering
plans starting as low as 15 a month by
going online only and eliminating the
traditional cost of retail mint mobile
passes on significant savings to you all
plans come with unlimited talk and text
and high-speed data delivered on the
nation's fastest 5G Network use your own
phone with any mobile plan and switch
easily in minutes with esim switch to
Mint mobile and get premium wireless
service easily with plans starting at
just fifteen dollars per month so if you
want to cut your Wireless plan down to
just 15 a month go to mintmobile.com
forward slash Yola they've teamed up
with the dope as usual podcast to bring
the savings to you
all right all right hold up real quick
real quick let's get on to this and
we'll light some joints it's like a
hip-hop history lesson people don't know
they're very original The Click
E40
I'll put that on the click the click oh
that's nice we just got dusted I never
trusted them Busters this is hard Mr
Flamboyant
yeah wow I did a show in Vallejo and uh
be legit and levitty came out and and
then in your city I think you're gonna
be that big
he's skinny now he's skinny now like big
boy from the radio skinny nope wow yeah
he lost all his words
yeah yeah he's like lowercase B Legit
all right here we go wow these are
classic we got a couple more come on
live from Fresno County jail remember he
did no way yeah I got that right I never
heard this no
you've heard some of it live from Fresno
County did it over the whole phone the
whole thing different
sick they used like 22 I think
wow that came out yeah
what year did you die like what kind of
run are you talking about you're 34
years old damn man you died in 2004.
yeah so he was out for the whole 90s
basically like he was popping from 2099
to 2004. it was a bit I'm surprised he
wasn't on TV
24 was live it's not too many Bay
artists that are embraced outside of the
region at the rate day he was you feel
me like they're selling out shows in
Kansas City you know a lot of artists
for many reason can't go to Kansas City
like he was it was just different and
the energy was like the everything you
hear and feel in the bay is Dre yes you
can put on feeling myself at any moment
in the bay and everything is going to
change Mexico you could go into Walmart
and put on feeling myself on the speaker
and it's gonna be active yeah
Marty's from New York he's from New York
so he has a whole different style of
music or like growing up on a different
wave of music do you uh do you not enjoy
Bay music I didn't really know about it
as much like all this he put me on to
all this I knew about the Jacko because
cormega put him on his end of his
mixtape as a bonus track and that led me
down the track path for a little bit but
other than that I mean I knew E40 Too
Short all that obviously but this is all
like history to me that I appreciate
yeah two more all right come on do you
know doobie AKA sugar wolf I didn't get
heavy in the Doobie but of course I know
doobie because I'm from College Park
duby's running crazy they're right up
the street so we we had to interact and
see all of them but I never got to get
into doobie heavy I Gotta Go Peep it I
gotta check it out especially for B like
you know that 90s kind of rap it's just
like this is the best version of that
yeah
you ever listen to
Deltron 3030 Del the Funky Homo Sapien
from hieroglyphics
we were just talking about Ira that's
hilarious nope that's one of the best
albums ever that is a story of a bat a
rap battle a rapper that does battles in
space and it's a story about him coming
up getting enough money to get a
spaceship and go battle all these
entities bro but is it like lyrical
Miracle stuff
I guarantee when you listen to that
you're gonna go damn a vocabulary sucks
it doesn't make sense on some of it it's
like describing how mechanics work and
it's like bro what is happening but the
rap battle parts are sold I gotta peep
it I gotta peep it last one I know you
knew this I know you know this all right
last one I just had to bust this one out
in a major way The Tonight Show Dilo oh
okay yeah classic DJ Fresh DJ Fresh DJ
friends I got like 30 of his mixtapes
dude man you wanna you know one of my
favorite DJ Fresh joints uh with uh
nefta Farrell that's the Pharaoh that's
a good one too that was that was more
recently no not the recent joint when he
did uh they didn't do like the product
but he did Mobil would never when Neff
was first coming out man different
pocket different really yeah DJ Fresh is
I think so underrated man right I feel
like if you say that out loud and people
go DJ Fresh we're homies now man he been
attacked now he's been trying to get me
to do something for a minute but he keep
like the packs he keeps sending me they
ain't the one man send me the fire send
me the ones you'll be sending them I
like Epic have like that's my DJ Fresh
project yes it's a night show so I
wanted to make it happening badly but I
got it got it I need the fire I need the
fire I feel like when producers send me
packs they like they they be trying me
first so they don't send me oh they
don't send me the top tier yeah thank
you sir but you know I need I need the
best of this is this is intense this is
intense
you'll be just a casual passing yeah but
we we these are little ones yeah these
are the little ones we're uh it's
morning you know I'm trying to ruin your
day I got a day ahead of me so I won't
smoke too much but I would like it you
smoke blunts huh no I smoke joints okay
because that was racist no because the
way you like I'm just kidding it's yeah
it's another way of lighting like this
like this like this
just the tip only break it off let me
see
and like just the tip
and then once it gets burning like this
then inhale and then light it again like
this look at ready just so you light it
perfect you gotta make a tutorial on
that watch yeah
okay that we don't have to burn off the
tip because I I didn't do so many blocks
boom split the tip yeah let it catch on
fire a little bit now hit it and light
it at the same time
done
there you go all right we're running
don't play with me
professional Marty hold on go for it sir
you're on the car you're on a rolling
stone article today did you see it
happen oh that was today oh yeah oh bro
congratulations that's fresh as hell you
just woke up and saw that
yeah yeah nice it's a beautiful name
nice hell yeah that's a major thing
especially for somebody from California
not even that
and the picture that they use as a
picture I took in my backyard with my
best friends perfect you can't beat it
perfect you can't beat it no wait wait
was this a did you know this was coming
obviously yeah we've been working we've
been working on something uh really big
with them so this is just like this is
one piece of what we're rolling out
today because I noticed it was with into
it and it's surrounding like financial
literacy basically yeah right can you
explain what that means so into it
basically tapped me in to do something
really cool
um
to basically be myself but to to help
emerging artists the same way that we've
already been doing but with some uh
Financial backing and with uh some more
grander support so yeah we'll be doing
something with them where we um
basically allow an indie to
to get on a track that that we're going
to be creating with with me someone who
doesn't have as much following and
backing and um we're going to really be
pushing that track heavy and it might
land in a really Grand Place at the end
and it's going to be dope and then
whoever wins damn I don't know about
this because it's such a fun y'all just
gotta stay focusing because it's such a
it's such a dope it's a really great
opportunity
and that seems like it's right in line
with the whole mission of your label
good company right right right similar
ethos right this is things that we were
already doing so it was dope that we got
tapped in to do this because it's um
alive we're gonna do that anyway it's a
very unique situation you're doing with
your music though
um allowing your fans to almost be part
of your story this is really great weed
it don't hurt this is a lemon it's a
lemon strain it's fire so what I'm
saying it's really unique the way you're
doing it because you're allowing people
to like you say essentially Buy in
shares for projects is that what this is
yeah so percentage of revenue from uh
distro so everybody sees like the
standard calculation online a million
streams is four thousand dollars so I
allow people to buy percentages of
Revenue so say if you buy five percent
of a song and a song does a million
streams you're going to get 200 off of
it but you keep getting that introverted
to it right so never stops if over the
lifespan of a song a song does 50
million streams whatever you're gonna
get whatever percentage of that for the
rest of your life it never goes away
nobody's ever had that model before
right this this the new this is the
first we're the first
what matters like what we know through
our podcasts and through YouTube is that
like quality matters when it comes to
the community You're Building you don't
need a huge amount of people to be able
to be a profitable artist and it seems
like you're really innovating when it
comes to that right and a lot of
different areas from the live shows to
just how you're putting out your music
and building your team and trying to
like
build your audience with your own career
it seems like in a lot of ways
really super Innovative and it reminds
me of him and how he's grown his YouTube
channel and the podcast you could really
capitalize and monetize off just a
hundred people if they really [__] with
you when you're genuine I think I have a
hundred fans who spend at least a
thousand dollars with me in a year you
feel me just a hundred so it's like I
can make a hundred thousand dollars off
just a hundred people because I really
take care of that 100 too like I'm I'm
giving them splits they're getting music
they're getting product when they come
they come into the crib they get loved
and it's green like we have some fans
that are really like family now like man
some of the kids like uh we got a lot of
little homies so they'll come and
perform and stuff and they're like can I
have your number and they'll text me and
be like I love this song you know like
they get a real genuine experience and
um you just can't beat it but that's how
you cultivate that audience some people
got millions of followers and fans but
it's not there's no true connection like
there's two percent they're not really
riding like my fans are like no that's
my boys that's my dog
when rappers and stuff like people that
I know even from my hometown or wherever
asked me like advice on how like what
should I do it's not enough to record
like and so you need to build a
community that's first and foremost they
need to like you the music is just what
you do by Nature you're doing that you
put out 21 albums correct
25.25 now it was probably 21 like two
three months ago stop it
full length out like yeah over 10 tracks
type [__] uh some over ten some seven
some fifteen some Twitter it just
depends on what mood we in
damn you're recording all what's your
schedule like because I know from the
music side what do you how much you
recording on The Daily I don't record
every day at all but when I do record I
record a lot of me like last time we
were in La we're out here for what two
three days two days and I probably left
with like like 11 yeah some wow so I
make I and I was a light day you know we
did a trip to La uh about a year back
and we left in three days we left for
like 21 tracks so I just record in
abundance when I do record I'm good I'm
already a little bit just from listening
I could tell like you probably you're
like one take and shut a lot everything
is one take yeah we do another take down
there every song in my catalog is one
thing we even got one album we recorded
like we filmed it so you get to see that
process live like everything was just
wow you feel me that's not the case with
most rappers I've been in the most
painful Studio sessions oh man 10 000
takes bro and that's the thing like oh
man yeah it'd be rough it'd be rough and
I also write fast so sometimes it's just
it has just waiting on people but yeah
it's a it's not typical do you sit down
and write songs at a time or is it more
like little bits and pieces and then you
kind of like gather those I usually
write everything in at once once yeah
um nah I'm in the phone yeah
they all on the phone but yeah I usually
uh once I get an idea I try to see it
through in that in that moment sometimes
I'll have little fleeting bars that are
just like quotes that I'm like ah that'd
be great somewhere yeah for the most
part I write it yeah I love that when I
when I used to be into music I would
like record it into GarageBand as I was
writing it and then listening he was
rapping yeah what she was rapping about
ending up here love it
from Buffalo and Marty's from the ghetto
yeah
bro you like Billy now yeah yeah loved
it he was going to come on yesterday
right after you couldn't get up here is
he out here for Rolling loud he's here
right now it's all right love it
yeah but they had a very similar come up
like the whole Griselda is like man and
I wish
I wish I could see because they didn't
dock it I wish we could have seen
because I know in Buffalo it's probably
like the energy probably like this
documentary though he'd been filming for
licenses he's been posting a bunch of
wild [__] from Buffalo from like 2001.
he's supposed to been filming for that
long just but even back then they were
they were putting on mixtapes back in
when I was in high school and still till
this day like when you go look at
catalog there's only so many artists
that really got cat alone Griselda every
single one gun
and then you currency Larry June like
filthy like there's only so many yeah I
was gonna bring it first but I wasn't
sure if you were like oh it was before
my [__] I was gonna bring a filthy rich
out no come on
Legend from the statement it it take a
lot to make it out the bay
you feel me at at any level at any level
if you could lead a bay and people know
who you are and know your music it's
different because we have no industry no
infrastructure no me so it's a different
grind it's the same in Merced they are
the whole wave we gotta we got a kid
from Merced right now named Mali monster
when I tell you he's one of the greatest
he's going to be one of the greatest to
do it and he's from Merced he's going to
be the first like I mean well G GB is
from GB I'm sorry man
[Music]
um
yeah we had him here man it's gonna be a
new wave it's gonna be beautiful because
it's always dope to see those cities uh
finally get like a superhero in the
fight you know it's like yes all of us
don't have a a hero in the in the fight
especially in hip-hop so when you
finally get one it's like yeah
it's like you got your own team exactly
like Vallejo don't have a team but we
have rappers we got Mac Dre so it's like
that's our team you know
good company Hood crying just just let
him rap to you okay so when I'm
listening to music I know is you say
some funny ass [__] what is you oh you
must watch some funny ass [__] there's
got to be something you're watching what
is what did you watch you're five years
younger so it's not like it's a huge age
Gap what were you watching coming up
because there's got to be something
hilarious you watch Scott I don't even
know if it was specifically what I was
watching in terms of like entertainment
I was watching my family and I got a
funny ass fan like my uncle was my mom
my pops just my entire family is funny
as [__] my uncle
um named John McDonald he was on like
Comic View and all that yeah before he
passed away yeah and uh he was a
comedian and he was really funny but
it's just in the lineage like my whole
life I've been growing up just watching
people roast each other at the highest
level if you come to my house you're
going to laugh and you're gonna get
roasted
different way like his life right it's
just different all of my homies are
hella funny so uh just yeah my life was
kind of geared towards that it comes
across your video you can tell like it's
always comedic right yes music videos we
always throw likes on comedic element in
it cause like that was my favorite [__]
as a kid comedy I watched um
I didn't really have like a
entertainment filter when I was growing
up I watched whatever my mama watch you
feel me so I got to see everything I got
to get all the comedy that was crazy all
the tea the South for you know I got
everything same I want to see a rapper
and a stand-up like all tour together
bro
I'm writing a stand-up I'm going to do a
rap set blend it with a stand-up thank
you thank you exactly
Gambino did it bro he's fine he got it
he's got a dope low standing but he
didn't blend both he didn't rap and do
it I like that but he's got a really
dope stand up too that's a real
performance yeah especially you kind of
weave back and forth in between and our
shows are already kind of like that like
throughout my set I'm always kind of
joking and laughing but this would just
be kind of more formatted the stretch
that structure yeah that's dope as hell
actually what I found let's talk about
your live shows real quick all right so
you do your booking different then I
work with a lot of comedians like all
the biggest ones I was in there booking
and all that for a long time
can you try to explain how you do the
proud to pay and how like
you might sell out a show and still not
be profitable from it so first uh our
first prior to pay shows were basically
we didn't do no tickets prior you just
have to pull up oh [__] you get your
ticket you get in you pay whatever you
want at the door right and uh all those
shows we took losses majorly because you
know even if someone really wants to
support you no one wants to pull out
that much money at the door with people
behind with a whole line right so we end
up innovate and Innovative and I met uh
my partner ibrima he owned a ticket
platform called what's TBA it was black
owned it was some new [__] some fresh
[__] they was doing
um I got with him and we partnered and I
was uh just kind of explaining the
process of what I wanted to build with
the offer based side and the proud to
pay side and he was able to build it he
was able to build the tool because I was
doing the backyard shows offer base but
manually we had a spreadsheet I would
have to go in and select and highlight
he had to send out an offer like we had
to do it all man Cash Out PayPal vimo
but we made it happen so we finally got
a tech behind it so now it's offer based
so like we'll announce the show you can
go in and buy your ticket you can put an
offer for it uh some some of them I'll
do it all for base but I won't restrict
the offer so you can pay a dollar you
can pay 200. auction almost yeah you pay
whatever you want to get in right so
that's how yeah we we could sell out a
show of 500 people but we still may lose
money but the difference is like if I
was to set my ticket price at say forty
dollars fifty because the type of show I
give is a show that really should cost a
couple hundred dollars like there's no
you can go to one of the biggest artist
shows and come to mind and you're gonna
be like I'd rather be there right so I
could charge hundreds but my thing is
like if I charge that less people will
get to get the experience right when you
open that door there's not too many
shows that I don't sell out if I'm
coming it's it's selling out or it's
very close because everyone has the
ability and I look at it as like when
they're in the building even if they
only paid a dollar to get in the
building if they buy a hoodie that's 20.
if they if they don't buy anything but I
Inspire them and they donate that's
extra paper or if they go home be like
damn next time you come I'm going and
the next time they gonna pay 40 50
because they like man I remember yeah so
it's like I'm still going to get it back
you hear me so I don't really lose I
only lose money but I don't actually
lose in in life that's how we came up
yeah I always say the best way to
support hello homie best thing you can
best way to support us
bro and that'd be so simple that
um it really makes you
it really Alters your perspective on the
industry and everyone that you kind of
deal with because people tell you they
support you but it's like you haven't
shared it right I remember I was in um
like Dylan's talking with a label and I
was like uh just share my [__] first let
me see if y'all really [__] with me and
it was like I can't do that and it's
like for that
what are we talking about free what are
we talking about
like did you really just make that just
say you don't want to you don't have to
lie and say I can't do that you've had
social media you feel me but Sharon is
that simple you feel me no it's so true
like our fans are we just did our first
tour of meet and greets because of GB I
went to Merced we didn't meet you at a
shoe store I'm like damn people will
show up so we went all across the
country and did it right the fans are so
for real when you first time Seven Years
bro I've been watching your story what's
this show is it like the podcast live or
YouTube no I do uh the tour was just oh
standing saying hi to people talks to
each fan one by one for 30. thousands of
people sounds like me it was sick just
talking because you know you're Sour
Whatever so you didn't even perform
nothing no it was literally just you
just standing
wrapped around the building
it was so people to even be down and
just pull up for that shows like your
character and you wouldn't believe it
bro like damn about to get teary like
because I looked and I went oh hell yeah
there's some people like cool like fool
look around the corner and it was all
the way down the block I couldn't it
made me my whole perspective change like
you guys really are here because it's
fun you connect with people like with
music they say something they'll stick
with you forever like that's why I like
that fool but when you're talking
speaking to people it's like your friend
special social media there might be
somebody at home watching us like damn I
feel like I'm in the room with you they
get like that [__] changes like after
every show then there I'm I'm the next
hour and a half two hours I'm just
talking hugging people greeting people
before each show I go out there and um
that experience really Alters everything
like
when people talk about me online in
terms of their experience is always a
paragraph an essay you feel this whole
dissertation on what they experience
it's amazing because
you know when you're like down tired no
more I'm gonna go but you see the next
person's face like yo your face juicing
me up bro right because you know what
who did you look up because could you
imagine if I saw that phone how Juiced
that'd be if you said what's up let
alone give me five minutes of his time
right
that's how you build the community
that's why people are showing up and and
five years you're gonna look back or you
were one of the first people showing up
my shows you're still here bro and they
still here still there still there still
supporting stuff bro and that's the
thing you have to build like uh it
builds lifelong fans exactly like I'm
excited to see some of these people who
are in our group now in 10 years and
their kids grow up it's like older and
it's just like we get to witness that
you feel me off music and it's positive
and you get to see people's lives so I
know you got the DMS you change my life
thinking of this and trying to get out
of active and doing it and I'm stepping
up or I'm in a different situation
somebody named his daughter after my
wife and we came to I was like my
daughter Rose I'm like she cried I was
like yeah dude this is a different
experience what we do is it's like the
same level of like I Love You full thank
you for being here right one person
showing but you have to show up and you
did everything that's a different level
of influence like anybody can stream a
song but if you can get someone to call
a babysitter to get in their car to plan
out their day to go sit with you for
three hours to come if you can get
someone to do that like that's Michael
Jackson You Feel Me Like streaming is
whatever no one cares about a trophy for
stream but like when you get a [__] to
leave their house and drive to rest
course and pick up your album and walk
catch the bus and walk like that's real
impact exactly right it makes you feel
like oh I gotta go harder you did all
this for me I never met you it's crazy
bro and that face you have right now
that's the face you're supposed to have
when you're [__] dude I love it man no
it's true it's just like it makes you
excited all over like a little kid you
got Juiced up so speaking of that uh the
first time I ever felt that I went to a
tech nine show and I was 18. wow well
you're really a hip-hop guy yeah yeah I
was I mean I loved it and I went there
and this fool did like a Temptations
line dance with Calhoun and uh ah I feel
terrible right now but there's a bunch
of other people and did a little like a
Temptations Dance all the smoke and the
and the wind tunnel it was the best show
I ever seen from it and it was an
independent artist you know what I'm
saying when he was still painting his
face getting talk [__] talked to him
Tech is a majorly independent like Tech
is um
they got major money major label money
like he's majorly in the which is so
beautiful like
man it's such an insight and a blueprint
to what's real like it don't matter if
you on the radio or not like that's real
like you bring thousands Indy you feel
me and the kids may not know who he is
but if everyone knows he exists still
like he has his his space in this crazy
to cultivate without being on Radio and
on TV for like 25 years
man we're just talking the other day and
uh we were talking about like
advertising I was like man when people
used to pay someone to go hung up
hundreds of posters that was your
Facebook ad yeah right like that was you
spending your money
Target targeting audience targeting
anybody
it's crazy but now the reach is this we
can have audience in Finland which is
beautiful now a question about that so I
think it was 2021 you had I read you had
4 000 Instagram followers right what
like was it a deliberate thing I know
you said like I posted once a day for 30
months or whatever what was the game
plan that helped you get so much
momentum so quick starting from
basically zero like two to three years
ago
um as far as social media goes
tiara
my pops those were like like
direct motivations and things that kind
of came in that changed but um
consistency and that spark just kept
getting bigger like we were so
consistent and I remember really the
first thing was um I had paid uh this
blog called rap Marathon it was like 150
or 200 for a post and I paid them to do
the post they did the post and um wallow
seen it on there so that was the first
Spark and then from wallow everybody's
seen it then Charlemagne and then D.L he
and you just had it just kept sparking
and we kept staying consistent every
time someone seen me somewhere and they
looked me up they can go find a hundred
things to become a fan yeah imagine if I
only had one you feel me like I gave
them 100 reasons to be a fan what was
the post was it an interview or just you
it was the 2021 freestyle oh okay in
front of the flower wall no it was in
front of like one of my homie's old
shots we used to work out of so this was
uh early and then Russ you seen it Etc
and then from there we just start kind
of
getting more momentum organically and
then I start running the ads like heavy
because I was like man if this reached a
hundred thousand two hundred thousand
people by itself imagine if I started
just thinking like yeah if they love it
then if I show it to this many more
people and I used to always go into
labels like man I just need a million
people to see me I just need a million
people to see me we found out a way to
get a million people to see it it's off
the label without the labor
I advertise heavy still because it's
like my content works and it's like
McDonald's is making trillions and they
still advertising are you talking
everywhere they send you [__] on their
hip-hop sites or like no I like yeah
Instagram YouTube Google
not even uh and we do seating for for
certain things like on different
platforms and that works as well that's
really great for organic too but with
the ads it's like like I just announced
the show in Houston yesterday right um
we already sold 150 tickets right I
might not post about the Houston show
again until the day of the show or the
day before but people are seeing my
every single day every day someone's
buying a ticket because they seen it in
Houston knows in Houston yeah see what I
do is I'll Target like when I do a show
I'll Target that region and like all the
neighboring cities within like 40 50
miles yeah and then the beauty of it is
this is what I did for other comedians
next time you go back now you got a list
of people that bought last time get
right back in front of them deliver
Marty's job
selling tickets out it's it's a Target
marketing but the way he's doing it is
different because for the comedians the
it's like structure for the venue they
don't give the The Comedians the control
to like sell their own tickets see
exactly and that's where um
you could lose you could lose people
right and they want you to do well yeah
come work here for 10 years then we'll
give you a good deal
and it's just bro it's too many hands in
the pot and there's too many third
parties having like a cut I don't wanna
I don't I don't I hate having to ask
somebody what I sold or how many tickets
I don't want to have to ask [__] what
for my own show yeah yeah wait on a
response in that situation yeah it's
always I like you but do I hate do I
have to hate you
yeah no you're fully Hands-On even our
booking agent's like no I'm just talking
to him like we're just text me yeah and
that's it come on shoot me a text call
like once I see like it's real or J or
it's a real thing it's like let's just
deal direct because it's going to be
easier than waiting on all these
different parties like we have some
things in place where there's a
middleman in between and we got up Wade
and someone else has to communicate on
our behalf and sometimes that's good
because you don't have to deal with
everything but uh sometimes for this
like I notice with my bookings
when we get places the relationship is
different because we already know each
other it's like you've been speaking to
me the whole time we good and man it's
just always love
seems like you've done thousands of
interviews yeah man we had a uh one day
uh we were working the content schedule
and um I was telling T I was like I need
a different interview for every day of
the week so I needed so I could be able
to cut the pieces up from those seven so
I was like all right let's get seven we
end up getting like 50. you feel me but
I could post a different interview clip
every single day of the week you really
do a great job of like alternating
between like crap man shout out to
Yellow [__]
it slots everywhere to make sure like
and it's funny because sometimes I'll
have a song post the same song a week
apart and I'll be like no we can get a
thing because we have so much but it's
like yeah every every day you're getting
something new and fresh and different
way
because people could love you and be
like yo I love you you don't post for
three weeks I kind of forgot about you
still love me I still love you though
you have to keep in people's face like
you say McDonald's like I'm not gonna
forget but you might here take this
flyer right and the only people that get
annoyed is the people who don't like
McDonald's and that's it
right bro yeah it's just an extra smile
or extra emotion during the day so the
question I didn't even ask do you have
brothers and sisters I have three
sisters you the only boy yep and the
youngest uh I'm the ah that sucks you
should get those you just get beat up
man that's crazy
everybody used to get beat up when you
say exchange fairly oh you were you were
good then how much older are there than
you
um my oldest sister I think is like six
or seven we're all like two two two so
she I think my oldest sister six years
apart from oh damn I said she was a man
and she should beat me yeah yeah mine
too but you know we usually get down
still
what was the moment where you're like yo
I'm big enough don't [__] with me eleven
yeah or 12 I think what was yours you
know you have it yeah probably probably
around that same same age right high
school but we also like um
All My Siblings is kind of like we all
like cool oh that's cool as hell my
sister is a menace no mines was too
early yeah let me retract that because
man one of our ride we had a rivalry we
hated each other for a minute I don't
know what it was it was just like man we
just grew up in a household where
everybody talked and everybody just it
was you know everybody reigned Terror on
everybody
right and the youngest so I got it and
my mom it was just my mom and my sister
right but my sister was a dick so when
she say something my mom would beat her
and then she'd leave the room go why
didn't you get your ass beat it's
because I'm not an [__] and she'd be
my ass for now oh that was the smallest
hilarious because there's always the
turning point was like I was screaming
so hard I started crying and soccer yeah
we've had that moment yeah
it's natural you know you gotta test out
the pride
I remember the day she smacked I was
like no not yet you're too big still you
beat my ass she's the wrestle and I used
to so she'd be mine sister scary
um all right so we have a little say we
want to we get into it real quick it's
called where you at where you at I'm
gonna ask you where are you at where are
you at so we're gonna ask you a series
of things like where you at with this
with us is that it's random everyday
things that you've never been asked
before wait yeah I mean I'm gonna do the
first one real quick all right and then
16 year old you walks in and tries to
fight you you're gonna beat the [__] out
of him or is he like gonna beat the [__]
out of you
I always ask that question because some
people were a menace some people were
soft but 16 year old you walks in
you're gonna win or lose
it depends
it depends on how skilled I am
like you know you're 16 year old so
right you think you'd be like nah [__]
it I'll beat the [__] it would be a draw
oh interesting if you've never had that
we've got so many people this question
never had a job it'd be a draw okay
[Laughter]
all right where you at with germs with
public door handles with like you
germaphobe in it are you putting your
sweater over your grabbing door handles
out there or not uh
not really no not really I'd be raw dog
in life
um not really yeah I don't I don't um I
don't care much unless I see some [__]
like now in the airport I don't be using
the Riders because of [__] on Twitter
they showed a video of all the bacteria
on it like if I don't see it I don't
really care what do you mean but I mean
I guess I'll be kind of flushing the the
airport toilets on my foot oh see yeah
me too always yeah because you don't
want to go oh nasty but it's also like
when I ride the escalator I'll be having
my hand on the rail so none of that [__]
[Music]
does your hand feel infected until you
sanitize it I'm like a level three germ
dude I think you're like level one germ
dude yeah yeah I'm not I'm not too
pressed unless it's you know I was it's
when I see nasty fools then I get like
hold your breath around this yeah but it
say it takes a lot to get to that point
where you like The Germ [__] when when
you get to the point where everybody
like
then it's like
it's like excessive
I was like yo don't get sick because
we're smoking and then you're gonna get
me sick today but they call me all right
mom they told me they're like all right
we'll get by that car then I'm just
saying there's a car coming like that
dude like I watched Final Destination
too many times to just not say hey
there's a car careful all right go go
Marty uh where you at with being
superstitious not knocking on wood
counting numbers in your head and other
weird stuff yeah nah I'm not really
superstitious I'm also I'm actually like
anti to the point on my ass like when me
and my daughter walked in school like
I'll pull around certain poles just to
be funny
I purposely try to I'll probably try to
walk under ladder
that's how that's how I'm like let me
see
you saying Bloody Mary jumping on cracks
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right where are you at with uh I
guess this is like where you at with
like fear if you had to buy yourself
jump out of a plane or go deep sea cave
exploring which would you choose if you
had to pick one
I'd rather jump out a plane yep me too
yeah yeah does that not phase you are
you not scared by like playing Heights
and stuff I think everyone's scared of
heights in some sort like no one opens
you don't open the door of a plane with
anyone in a heart don't start beating
um but I'm not unwilling if I have to
okay oh wow okay yeah really yeah okay
it's a different type of person anybody
willing to jump out of a planner like
even be open to the idea is different to
me yeah that's why Rosie jumped out of
the plane oh no she bungee jumped oh
okay she's ready though she do I'm
considered jumping out a plane a couple
times we just haven't got there yet but
I don't know if you do it Go Pro it and
then film a video of YouTube
we literally just seen somebody do that
right but if I do it it's gonna be
different get approach your angles do it
twice and get different angles right do
it twice that's not some [__] you just
do twice yeah but yo you landed let's go
back up uh-huh see why is it because
it's scary
right I mean after you do it the first
time you're not scared to do it a second
time but it's like you don't want to put
yourself through that con that's like a
shroom trip back to an intense one back
to back like that I'm gonna go I take 15
grams of shrimp I don't even like
getting on a plane after getting off a
plane
like that that's a lot I'm with you now
you want to jump out of one I hate
connecting flights
oh bro I feel that okay so yeah I'm not
jumping out of [__] go for it all right
so where you at with weed you have a
preferred are you like a weed snob do
you only if you had to pick two
questions are you weed snob do you have
strains that you only no I'm a liberal
okay you're you go to Open Door Policy
yeah with weed I I do any any any really
will do with me like I'm I'm open to
trying whatever
um I really do like when me and my mom
first smoking together we used to always
get uh
um blue what's it called Blue Dream oh
my God boy that was the best week ever
at that time were you just get it by the
way 2011. yeah no like um probably like
20 I think I started smoking again in
like 20
17 or 18. I stopped smoking for a long
time in 2018 you found your religion
yeah oh my God we used to just be hella
high just talking in Vallejo
yeah when did you and your mom started
smoking together that's cool um
probably like like 2017 2018 like she
had uh went through some heavy mental
[__] in like 2014
and she ended up getting prescribed like
weed instead of like having to do
traditional what traditional man super
weeds so she was smoking a lot and then
I finally just got to the phone where I
was like man let me love it because I
haven't I didn't smoke for a long time
since high school like five or six years
without smoking so um I just started
smoking with her and then it was just
like were you still making music when
you weren't smoking were you yeah but
like um not nearly at the rate that I do
now but I was always making hella music
but just like hobbyist
where's the weed in your process now
like as far as music goes is it it's all
in there probably every song you've
heard from the past year or two got some
weed in there
part of the writing process part of the
recording process part of the life
process yeah I would say is it lifestyle
at this point Yeah question real quick
does your mom let you smoke when you
were younger or is this like a thing
like I'm an adult you're trying to get
high now that you don't beat my ass uh I
don't think my mom knew I was smoking
when I was younger I don't think she
would have been like uh
it's over
I don't think I had to I just did
naturally you feel me but we didn't
really hide it bro we used to come in
the house so high and but you know like
so it was fine so did you know your mom
smoked me back then
um no I didn't know she smoked weed back
then but she used to drink a lot back
then but I never used to really see her
smoke weed for me to know like she was
she was getting that high but it
explains a lot what was the who brought
it up first when you first smoked weed
together who my age I know you got
prescribed would you like to smoke with
me what happened and what did you guys
do I think she was just smoking and I
was like let me hit that and and I think
from there just kind of you know mind
blowing to this one look at this it was
like damn that's crazy my parents were
hippies but they still weren't all cool
with weed with me at all but they smoked
weed yeah my dad was like I was Finding
he was a musician he kept it up in his
guitar case up in the attic do as I say
not as I did yeah that doesn't work it
does not work
all right uh
as far as what you like listen to on the
regular be a podcast YouTubers music if
you had to pick one stream to subscribe
to for Life what do you think it'd be
sad Guru
sad Guru what's that uh he's like an
Indian Mystic just be giving hella gems
and game and like life lessons really
yeah on a podcast
on on YouTube like he just got sad Guru
has as much content as I have for music
for just like life yeah like he he
actually is the blueprint for YouTube
and it's what sad Guru sad Guru I gotta
see this you have to correct you're
gonna learn something man it's gonna it
changed my life
it changed your life a YouTube channel
I mean not the YouTube channel yeah yeah
and he has great books like just older
man yeah yeah yeah oh gee no
let's not skip past that you're an
author also I'm an author as well author
yeah
yeah so
second book limit Limitless ten thousand
shot Theory can you tell us like briefly
or whatever like a synopsis what that's
about oh man and it's just a bunch of
Life gems and me kind of touching on the
10 000 shot theory is like you know
you've heard the same 10 000 hours I use
10 000 shots because I was just out of
your control right you got to let time
pass but in terms of shots you get to
control your output you could either
shoot 10 shots a day or you can shoot
100 or a thousand or whoever shoots the
most gets better right you don't have to
rely on the amount of time just your
effort and the book is kind of just
touching on that and just a bunch of
like life jams that I've used to
navigate where were you at success wise
when you put that out
would y'all Limitless last year
um I was still on the way up like
halfway yeah was there a moment that
like you were like damn that was a big
we just made a big jump
off this happening
for me I realized there was so many it
seemed like once you started doing the
shows in your backyard that's when it
became like nah you know what's crazy
though it was before that like when I
started rehearsing in the garage we
started getting a lot of people sharing
videos from men but it was man there's
been so many there's been so many just
an accumulation the first remember when
they asked oh you want the wrestling go
this is the same dude like a year and a
half ago I was on Tick Tock I was
commenting on like yo this was full for
the bay like this is hard as hell and it
was a lower shot
I got a weird memory I photographic
you're looking this way and like it's
like in the back it looks like there's
like a second story or something or some
people higher than you're on stage and
your rapping has the words over and when
we remember I was like I gotta find it I
gotta find the same video like a year
and a half ago I was like I don't know
who this is but this is hard sick as
hell and it's not some tick-tocky [__]
no it's not even like oh it's just bars
it's like to me my favorite artists are
all up on this wall right here you got
DMX you got time you got Nipsey you got
and it's like they were real artists
really getting shut off their chest just
because that's who they were and just
that's just what's gonna happen no
matter what this is coming out of them
because they're that type of they're an
artist and this is how they express
themselves that's for me how it is with
your music I never feel that I haven't
felt that since oh background Marty
doesn't listen to anything other than
what I just mentioned 2010.
I understand why but it's not like it's
a bad thing it's just like you know
what's dope about what I'm just saying
is like
we get that at shows like I I probably
have one of the very few rap shows that
60 year olds come to when 50 year olds
like it'd be old [__] at the shows
because they miss getting that feeling
they don't have DMX in them no more so
they don't get to get that feeling no
more so they come to our [__] now yeah
because it's not like it's really like
motivation music for people you're
talking about drama and you're talking
about things that go on in real life and
like yeah but it's not for ego though
which is like most rap it's just kind of
Norm yeah like I'm gonna kind of check
these boxes Flex culture try to run up
the things basically but you're like
who's going to be around in 2026 or
whatever Beyond yeah and with the
community You're Building
it's it's a cult cult movie classic it's
a show it's what it's truly what it is
right you can go to the store and when
you see someone that knows you and their
life is like shut up I love this full
it's a connection it's not just you know
I seen your music what's up bro
yes everybody I just want to do better
that's all
yeah it's the commonality right and if
you win they win because they're part of
it bro man you know what I mean yeah you
inspire people to try to you know even
if what was it we had a couple guests
but like yo you inspired me to do this
but I don't even do that but I'm glad
that we got that feeling you're like you
know what right yeah bro that's been the
dopest thing is saying how many
different niches we hit like I got chefs
and hairdressers and auto mechanics and
you know you got people in every field
but and this is what they use to like
navigate they feel get through that
storm the branch is like a when I speak
people come up like y'all want to make
videos I know people like it but if you
like it I guarantee there's another fool
out there like you that is gonna like it
if you got two fans saying yo this is
sick right you got two fans man like
that's better than zero right and and
there's a lane for everything like the
screamo music cat videos
like there's no way that they can
cultivate a fan base and you can't yeah
exactly there's billions of people who
enjoy
no no that's a great thing my thing is
like there's a billion people here and
one there was a time where someone was
like I'm just gonna post cat videos to
YouTube somebody would have been like
you're stupid
no one cares you feel me but they did it
and look
super true very good point if you can
make millions from posting cat videos I
think you're the smartest man in the
world sure no whoever was like yo my kid
he's talkative
toy unboxing that fool's a genius
Devil's ball and right I give it up
whole cultures crushing right now yeah I
don't know why
yeah but you know what because I was
like I grew up like a poor ass kid if I
got to go on my free YouTube app and
click and go wow I get to kind of
experience this toy I get why it's so
popular I understand that that's just
crazy as hell uh all right last one of
uh where you at before I forget where
you at with
UFOs paranormal activities things of
that nature we know Merced is haunted do
you believe
you have to see someone you go Pacheco
passed the 17. yeah you're out there and
I know you had to have seen something on
the one do you believe that there's
other alien out here
before it's starting all right we're
starting I don't think you build an
entire base around it if there isn't do
a waste of money on Area 51 if there was
nothing
thank you right that just wouldn't make
sense
you know like none of that none of that
makes sense if there's nothing and even
if there is nothing there's something
because it's like damn then what are you
hiding oh for real if that ain't it what
are you doing over here
there absolutely has to be and if it
isn't then there's something far worse
right because it's like well what are
you hiding I didn't even think about it
that way ever that's way worse right
like if that wasn't built for that then
it's like what y'all never thought about
that either right but no all that I mean
not even as well all that it has to be I
mean we've seen like
Plum Island you know like [__] seems
Plum Island is like um
like a place they used to supposedly do
experiments and there was a bunch of
washed up mutated animals just coming to
show around there uh I don't even
remember I used to just watch hella
hella you know conspiracy theories but
is it a conspiracy if a [__] could walk
there and see it
[__]
I'm right here
I can see it from the freeway see those
mermaid videos you're like whoa I don't
know I'm gonna know [__] but
if that's real that's scary as hell
those be crazy and yeah that's my thing
is like if it's not real then for what
purpose are you doing this right there's
something far worse if it's not real
yeah it's not reviews because you're
doing it since
1930 Fool's been psyched it's like not
for a newspaper article right
something's going on you ever heard of
uh Bob Lazar of course yeah that full
he's so convincing that I'm like you
better not be lying that'd be my thought
I'd be like
you can't be lying because you took it
too far that'd be my feeling is like
there's no way this [__] lying because
he took it too far and then you have the
Tory Lanez [__] and I'm like
what does that mean like he was he was
going all in that he was innocent like
he was going very very like the [__]
made the whole album so to me it's like
when you go to that length it ain't no
way you guilty because no one did no one
but then it's like damn [__] did you go
to Disney and you was guilty why even do
all that
but I get it [__] Gonna [__] you know
well it's like a thing it's like uh
we're fools accuse you if you accuse me
of stealing something I just steal I'm
gonna fight you do you know what I'm
saying but when people like you ever see
those videos you don't just let it
happen like I swear no you can take the
money then like you're a [__] you did
you know you did it right if you touched
me and I didn't do [__] we're gonna
fight to the death right so fools like
that like Barbizon are you referencing
his Rogan interview like did you see him
oh he got a Rogan interview no
I found out about him through like just
going through the the phase of
researching a bunch of [__] I didn't
know he had one
right I don't know probably the first
one was the one
it was hard for him to even talk he was
having like a migraine that's why I like
I was saying like he'd be the greatest
actor of all time if he really like was
just making all the that would be and if
he is
he's good right he would be too good but
I don't I don't I don't think he is I
don't think you can fake there's certain
people we've interviewed it's like he
can't fake this is you can tell this is
right core like we interviewed uh Larry
lot Larry Lawton is the America's
biggest jewel thief he used to do his
title some of the she talks about in
prison he's like always get acid just
[__] fry for days in prison because
he was just there for prison forever
like the way you speak there's not an
ounce of front in your body right I
could feel it when you talk you know
what I mean right it's like oh yeah
cracked him in the head
all right damn what are you Jesus Christ
right cool ass man though but yeah
bibles are there some people speak
there's just that feeling you get bro
right I don't think it's the same with
music and that's why people it resonates
with certain people like I said a
certain line could hook you forever
change everything yeah yeah certain
thing reference something I like too
like damn you like that too
it's true it's true I think I said the
word but I think that was the end of the
segment right yeah all right
um so I just want to make sure we got
this going on uh
I had I had your the latest name of your
album out I hate when life's going good
right I say that right yeah that's like
three albums ago it is I hate when
life's going great that's like three
albums ago October yeah oh you said you
put out three in the past three months
since yeah and it's the name of the
price your book also I I did it I I was
writing a book titled I hate when life's
going great but I didn't end up
releasing the book but uh I have a bunch
of [__] written that I was going to
release in tandem with that but uh uh
yeah I got so much to add now so but it
might still release
it's all streaming right nothing
physical can you buy physical CDs yeah
we did vinyls yeah yeah
I feel like that needs to come back I uh
I have an extensive ass CD collection
yeah and I just got into some records I
think being able to get something
tangible and go I'm supporting this yeah
and I get the artwork and I get the back
story remember that when you're a kid
open to see of course I don't think it
ever went away
that's all I don't even I think the
music just doesn't make people want to
buy it like they they were like oh CDs
are so no more but it's like no they
sell if people love the music people
still buy kids
people still buy mines in my in my
vinyls people just don't want your music
there's some bands that still just sell
CDs and vinyls
like you feel me that that's all it is
I I uh if I walked in like damn you got
that on vinyl oh yeah you've got this on
vinyl you're committed
spun it around like yeah take it
you got that on vinyl right because
that's a different commitment and most
people aren't willing to make that type
of commitment for the music they're
getting it's not like I want to go out
my house and buy vinyl music it's just
like I don't listen to it on radio yeah
that's a lot like it becomes a part of
your like but I've had these for
decorations 14 15 years this is my part
of me yeah so I feel like when that's
coming back we're not coming back but I
feel like you should do a special
episode and sell it exclusively on vinyl
watch
Watch What Happens because you have that
type of Base so do something special
that's not online that's the only way to
listen to this is on vinyl watch and
give me a percent because I just gave
you the idea don't cut me out I just
wanna I just want a piece of the piece
you got it don't trust me trust me 99.3
I love that that's an amazing ass idea
yeah uh-huh so you got you got the show
in Houston coming up and then you got a
slew of backyard shows coming up right
yeah The Residency is back so for the
rest of the year with that what else are
we looking like in terms Like Music
Drops and anything else in the works man
I have about 10 albums right now that
I'm just what done just sitting on that
we're working on visual content for now
and um
man it's just some great [__] so we're
really the music is never like the music
is coming no matter what I'm someone who
drops five plus albums every year like
yeah and that's like we we make music
often you feel me so that it's just
sometimes like I got albums that has
been sitting for the past two years but
I got albums I just made them up yeah
sounds like you use the majority of
songs you record though like a lot of
people yeah I don't I don't have a lot
that I I keep but we release them there
everything
why would you keep it though like if I
love it if you love it if you love it
share that [__]
it's just a lot of work I mean we do
content videos I want to have two
stacked up like you know
like two minutes
now what happened if you get sick that's
why we do it
just in case we got two yeah
right after we leave here man imagine
the world uh coming to a close and you
got a gun and you have two bullets okay
right we keep a full clip of ammo he's
not accurately depicting his clip we got
we got ammo yeah
and two for you guys it's like it's an
hour long so you bust that down
section but we videos oh like I have to
do a hop it might take like four or four
hours of film he might take like 18 20
hours to edit each is a full day for a
video so if we're too ahead like damn
two full days
but that's just beautiful like you guys
do this for a living right like this is
yours would you started getting paid two
years ago like it's just what we've been
doing for 10 years because it's fun and
he's been in the podcast for so long and
I stopped to do content and now it's
like the biggest Wii channel on YouTube
but from the community and fooled by
2013 I've been with you I'm like wow
bro and now when you get the realization
when [__] realize you can make more
money off YouTube than selling packs and
like
that's such a different shift because
it's like bro I don't have to risk
nothing I could just do this every day
this is all I have to do yeah
YouTube doesn't pay us because it's weed
content but we we have this I mean but
you get YouTube doesn't pay you but
everyone who watches right every form
like uh show up and say what's up and
that just drives you to do more stuff
brand sponsors money's like I'm doing
what I love when I'm eating or oh it
crushed in my 30s it was the fun my 20s
was the [__] right and it's just still
like I just don't want to be an old man
I made some money but it wasn't
you know I want to be Juiced right I
take my ass and [__] was tight
that's beautiful yeah that's what I'm
thinking
um so working everybody like buy not
everybody where can everybody grab your
tickets right now and it's a donation
based still it's offer based offer based
so yeah yeah
last night and it said make an offer
yeah but what the f yeah what do you
mean make can I just say that what is it
worth yeah you can but to work today so
I saw the shirt the prince man it's like
seven colors that should cost 14 to make
like people are giving you seven
that's why I do these on the back of the
neck I used to have it on the arm
because somebody told me it's only 50 of
the people and sometimes it's just like
sometimes that first buy is an entry
like I look at shows right if you're not
a little Russell fan you will be I
wouldn't want to pay 30 for a show but
if I'm not a little Russell fan I'd be
willing to pay 510 to see what he's
about but if I'm not I'm not going to
pay at all you feel me yeah so we make
it to where if you kind of I want to see
him but I don't know it's an easy choice
because it's like well [__] I ain't got
it and they like I got to spend hella
and then the people who really [__] with
me who like man I love this man I'm so
happy coming off into getting right like
you just we opened the door for
everybody to support it like if you
don't support me
you I give you every every incentive and
reason to support I make it very easy
man we who thought is that [__] scratch
he said make it easy for people to
support you I make it very easy for
people to support me so it's like
and they ain't never got to come up to
me be like oh man I fought with you I
did it because it's like well I would
have seen it
we make it
very platforming formula to have just
like you love me right come see your
show yeah you're gonna be putting all
the time
hey you think this is tight share with a
homie and it's his voice overlay it's
like that's all we ask that's what you
always say like you know high five me at
the store bro right and I'm a firm
believer of like
just giving great product to where it's
like people just want to share right
people want to like every time I hear a
great song that I don't have to even
talk to the artist or see the artist
it's like bro I gotta go put the homie
on me that's it of course that's it
yeah it's just a mutual uh being a good
person I know people say that but that
is the truth work hard and just believe
like yo I love doing it anyway and it
[__] will work out yeah you know what
I'm saying
um where can everybody follow you at
what's your socials I'm at La Russell on
everything
and then good company is my brand and
platform with the homies that's the web
established goodcompany.com
people can submit their music and stuff
there too right yeah so in my bio we
have a link and you could uh submit
music you could buy a gold card you
could put an offer for stock get tickets
to shows you can do just about
everything from there you could put in a
booking request if you want an interview
or a show or a birthday party whatever
you feel me so we we kind of give
everybody the space to do whatever they
need to do in terms of little Russell
most independent thing I've ever it's
the best in every page of all time thing
is you reap those benefits right back to
you're not working for another person
bro and you know what you got there's no
third parties you know like you're
you're usually dealing with me directly
if it's anything involving the Russell
um I like this man this path is sick
this is just a star I think it's the
beginning yeah it's the beginning you
know people like oh you had to go to rub
like dude let's just starting the spark
like it's the beginning this this it's
to keep the spark going and to keep [__]
flowing I feel that as an independent of
we specifically for here so I I feel
that like we have to get somewhere to
just get that platform we always say we
just need people to see it that's it
that's all I need give me 10 minutes and
if I don't then maybe I don't deserve
you right and that's always the thing
like when you got great product you just
need people to know it exists you never
have to change your product like it
works you just need more people to see
it and once they experience it we know
we got them so yeah that's where all
this helps bro it's so Monumental I
appreciate you exactly man so much
appreciate Tim's out of here too yeah
this is a this is fun oh yeah uh Marty
got anything else you want to say we
appreciate it we're going to let I
already know we're gonna look back on
this you come back again the show is
going to be even double where it's come
on oh for sure that that's that's why
people said yeah immediately like oh
yeah because we we know later the one
you girl you're talking to she's
oh she's on it she's been on it see
because we've been trying to make this
happen for a minute I've been to La back
a few times but we just had so much [__]
to do and she's been on it yeah
especially if you're up there I know
that that drive addicted 99 of the five
because y'all are Troopers
you haven't been up that way that's the
way we take to the Bay so yeah no I know
but like what what is it like it's just
the cow methane from the [__] that is
crazy that's all it is that's the type
of [__] like imagine you walk in the
house and it smells like man I'll be
sitting like that sometimes
shut the [__] up oh
I like good [__]
appreciate you being here man honor this
was great this is great thank you sir
guys from Marty O'Neal from La Russo for
my for my from me thank you guys so much
for being here this is for the dope as
usual podcast have a dope ass day
thanks for watching the podcast if you
thought this was dope you'll like this
episode too and don't forget the best
way to support the show tell a homie